hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and more specifically welcome to
the encyclopedia where today we are
going to be tackling the rather
insurmountable topic
of one isaac netara a very difficult
character to examine when it comes
purely to nenu's because he stands so
far and above almost any other that
we've seen in the series usually these
encyclopedia videos are based on
examining how characters have rather
creatively structured and crafted
abilities based on their limitations the
problem in this case being that word
limitations because for all intents and
purposes netro doesn't really
have those in fact he was even
recognized by the ant king marowam as a
rare example of one that had transcended
human limitations through sheer effort
alone but the thing that impressed
meruem most was netro's mastery of
pressing the subscribe button for the
new world review thus allowing him to
receive regular hunt on content uploaded
straight into his youtube feed so please
do feel free to transcend your own
limits by pressing this delightful red
button as well but netero and nen really
cannot be explained as simply as many
other characters more so than any other
netro harbors a deep connection with his
aura one that was forged through a task
that drove him to the brink of madness
at the age of 46 netro enamored and
grateful to the very concept of martial
arts decided to dedicate his life to
giving thanks and he would do this by
offering 10
000 punches every day before collapsing
in exhaustion to rest briefly and then
rinse and repeat this worship
this process took netro 18 hours to
complete on his first day's worth of
bunches however after performing the
ritual for two years straight netro was
able to complete it before the sun had
even set and then another two years
after that netro was capable of offering
10 000 punches in less than an hour
having surpassed all preconceived bounds
of human physicality however he did not
neglect his mind either because as the
time to perform the ritual decrease
netro devoted more and more time to
prayer and he proceeded to do this for
an unknown quantity of time before
finally returning back to civilization
as one of the greatest and most
terrifying nun masters that this world
has ever known and i suppose what's
important to note about nen at this
early stage is that aura manipulation
occurs as a direct response to emotion
drive and desire
and you will rarely meet a character in
hunt hunter who is more driven than
isaac netro someone who is willing to
dedicate years and years of his life to
such a seemingly simplistic action and
from there the aura response is dictated
by aura quantity and if you possess a
rather large amount like natural then
this is going
to result in a truly profound ability or
even set of abilities
and now before we even go into netro's
golden funky statue we should note that
he is not only a master but quite
possibly the undisputed master of the
basic principles of nen such as 10
renzetsu and hatsu
as well as the many advanced
applications such as ko shu in kanryu
whatever it doesn't matter if it's
non-related netro is well versed in it
and we know this because whilst we have
not seen netro display many of the basic
or even advanced principles prominently
he did serve as the grand master of the
shingen ryu school of kung fu
and this is the only known organization
in the series which teaches nen
as a formalized study and not only that
but netra also served as the essential
founder of the institution which to be
clear the shingen ryu school may have
existed prior to netro but it was he who
took it over
and incorporated the rigorous study of
nen into the program as such nataro was
often regarded by others as the most
powerful nen user in the world however
netro himself disputes this on multiple
occasions such as when he states the
following it's been more than half a
century since i was the most powerful
nene master you two and i are probably
evenly matched at this point the two
people netro was referring to in this
case being moral and nov which is how we
know for a fact that netro was at the
very least lying about this latter part
as he would go on to demonstrably
eclipse both moral and nov in every
aspect
of nen during the chimera antar and that
is something to very much bear in mind
netro is also exceptionally skilled at
hiding his true power
not one character in hunt hunter has
ever been able to accurately measure
nesro like for example during the hunter
exam kilauea severely underestimated him
and even as recently as the chimera
antar king maruem consistently thought
of netro as less of a threat than he was
which is an interesting phenomena that
seems to accompany students of the
shingen ryu school of kung fu for
example both biski and wing
also possess this ability to completely
shroud their potential and in a way it's
almost like a very advanced application
of zetsu
it doesn't really matter though because
whatever it is nataro's definitely got
it and with that said we now turn to
netro's net affinity which is another
debated topic because it's never
actually stated in the series however
naturo has
been identified as a natural enhancer in
two different hunt hunter data books and
the reason why we need to maintain a
healthy level of skepticism surrounding
this
is because the data books are
notoriously inaccurate with various
details mostly concerning names and
timelines the data books are also
highly highly unlikely to have been
written by togashi himself and that
always brings up the inevitable question
of canonici in this particular case i'm
going to dismiss that question outright
though because it has been published in
two different sources approved by
well the publisher and until stated
otherwise that's just what we have to
work with with that said netro does fit
in with the typical personification of
an enhancer
simple and determined with their words
and actions being dominated by their
feelings
although i do think an argument could be
made for him being a transmuter but
not in this video the reason why netro's
net affinity is important though is
because it informs the construction of
his crowning ability the 100 type
guanine bodhisattva and this is an
ability in which we see netro's
determination manifested allowing him to
either conjure or emit a golden deity
capable of striking enemies at
unfathomable speeds
and you could potentially call it an end
beast but actually acts more like a
puppet construct it doesn't have a life
of its own and it is entirely controlled
by netera and it functions as follows in
order to initiate an attack or movement
netero must first bring his hands
together as if in prayer and then signal
one of the 100 possible motions for the
hands to make so it's actually a very
very difficult puppet to make move
because the prayer motion has to be
repeated before
every new movement and not only that but
if netro moves too far from the statue's
range during combat then he also needs
to unsummon and then re-summon the
statue to a new spot and i would
actually go so far as to say that this
ability would be fairly useless for
anybody who is not isaac netaro because
it's quite clunky and inefficient
however for a man who is capable of
punching over 10
000 times in less than an hour this is
pretty brilliant in fact due to his
absurd speed netra can perform both the
prayer and the assigned hand action
together in less than 0.1 of a second
which not only gives the illusion that
the guanine statue was moving as if it
had a life of its own but it is actually
moving much faster than any human
possibly could
very much epitomizing and manifesting
the ultimate power of prayer based
punches
although quite interestingly this leads
to a bit of a contradiction of meaning
because to get all weird and into
textual for a second it's worth stating
that the generated statue of guanyin
appears to be crying and in the manga
there are even points where these tears
are shaded in a manner that resembles
the effect of blood and you could say
this is because guanine is actually
labeled as a goddess of mercy and
compassion you know two qualities that
netro really does
not possess which rather ironically his
primary opponent meroem did but
that's a whole other discussion however
this crying effect may very well be the
result of using the form of guanyin for
a directly violent purpose
and in general it's just very
interesting to see that this form is
what manifested from netero's drive and
desire his entire life has been
dedicated to the worship of violence
not so much in a gratuitous way but his
entire life's purpose basically boils
down to battling an unstoppable
adversary who would ideally
eventually kill him so i guess guanyin
is a symbol of the oxymoron of netro's
ideals the fact that he is really only
at peace when engaged in conflict and
not only that but incredibly stressful
and potentially life-threatening
conflict now in terms of all the fun
technicalities and such the only solid
affinity we can attribute to the 100
type guanine bodhisattva
is that of manipulation netaro is quite
clearly manipulating the statue to do
his bidding and that really is the core
of the ability which if netro were an
enhancer would speak volumes to his
sheer mastery of men
as manipulation would be a rather
unfriendly affinity to invest heavily
into i do have to say though in all
honesty i don't think netaro's net
affinity actually matters in the grand
scheme of things because no matter where
he lands on the nenring his skill and
aura quantity is so great that basic
affinity limitations are practically
meaningless once again adding to the
common theme of netro
as something of a transcendent being but
in terms of the statue itself this can
only be achieved via two mechanisms
either emission or conjuration or i
guess specialization if you wanted to
get semantic and i don't blame you if
you do because i
do that a lot but assuming natural is an
enhancer only emission or conjuration
and conjuration would be the natural
thought because the entire practice is
geared towards bringing physical
constructs into existence
however it is also possible to do this
viral mission as well it's not clear
exactly how but there are many many
examples of emitters creating nene
beasts and such like knuckle sakura or
razer's 14 devils
both of which are incredibly unlikely to
use conjuration due to it being their
least friendly affinity so that can't be
discounted from netro in fact as an
enhancer using a mission to create the
statue would make a lot more sense as it
would be easier to dip into but speaking
of it's not actually clear whether or
not netro uses enhancement in the 100
type coin in bodhisattvar at all the
only vague argument you could make is
that perhaps he uses aura to enhance the
statue thus making it much more powerful
and durable which i can potentially see
if he was an enhancer then it would make
a lot more sense to either conjure or
emit a basic statue and then use his
natural enhancement to make it
effectively indestructible and this is
because it would cost him a lot less
aura to do it that way rather than to
conjure or emit an already
indestructible statue this is all just
huge wild amounts of speculation though
so moving to another confirmed affinity
the 100 tab guanine bosatva does also
make use of clear transmutation and it
does so through the zero hand technique
a nice hidden 101st option of netera and
this is quite notable for being an
attack that does not necessarily require
the full prayer motion to be made as
natural was missing an arm at the time
he performed it in the series and in
this case the prayer comes purely from
the heart which results in the guanine
statue appearing behind an opponent
embracing them in its hand things
and then proceeding to fire every last
drop of netro's raw aura in their
general direction or actually i
shouldn't say
raw aura because it is being clearly
transmuted into another substance which
was described as being fired in a flare
like a dazzling star and it also almost
certainly makes use of a mission as well
in order to you know actually fire
whatever that transmuted substance is
regardless it is a pretty terrifying
attack that makes the ultimate use of
netro seemingly infinite or reserves
and against anyone who is not like some
sort of ant king then they would
immediately die without question
although very few others would have
pushed netro to the point of actually
using zerohand which is a surprisingly
big problem for netero actually his net
mastery did reach the point where there
was no human opponent really capable of
challenging him and for someone who had
dedicated their life to the pursuit of
martial arts and challenge this became
quite unsatisfying and i think points
like that speak to neta's power far more
than any actual demonstration could
because we know in great detail the kind
of maddeningly powerful people who exist
in hunt hunter you know the hisokas the
enemies the crawlers of the world in
fact you could even throw in the chimera
and royal guards as well and not one of
them is
in any way capable of standing up to
netera and we did see this in action
with nefapito actually
pito very briefly tried to engage with
netro before being promptly swatted away
in a single strike
unable to even catch sight of what had
hit them and this could either be
because netro was coating guanyin in a
layer of in or it could simply have been
that netro was just so
fast crafting and using the statue that
it was unable to be seen by peter each
of which are equally as possible but in
the end it doesn't really matter the
fact is that someone like pito is
already completely out of this world
when it comes to nen
and netro exists far above even that but
what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt on
content then please to go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunt and glory delivered straight into
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review
and i'll see you next time